the stranger things franchise has become
hugely popular since the show first
premiered in 2016.
the science fiction horror series
centers around a group of young boys who
meet a mysterious powerful young girl
that they call
11. though not much is known about
stranger things season 4 fans are
anxiously awaiting for news and
recently netflix delivered a new teaser
trailer for the show's fourth season
just dropped which gives us a pretty
creepy look into the upcoming trials
facing l in the gang
we left off season 3 with chief jim
hopper seemingly dying
11 disconnected from her powers and the
super best friends divided
no specific plot points for season 4 are
known but the young stars have promised
it will be the darkest yet
let's take a look at the new teaser and
break down everything that's going on
the teaser starts with shots of a clock
and a video camera that looks like it
has the number five on its lens before
cutting to two kids playing on a painted
rainbow on the floor of what looks like
a hospital room
fans who've watched previous seasons may
recognize this as part of the rainbow
room the creepy named research facility
where eleven and other kids were
imprisoned for experimentation
the children in the teaser also have
buzzed haircuts much like eleven did in
season one
next we see shots of different toys
considering the camera shot from earlier
it looks like the kids are being
monitored as they play with different
intellectually stimulating games
the plinko disc lands on the number 7
which may allude to a new test subject
who will become a focal point in season
4.
back in season 2 11 met 8 another
product of the rainbow room the
disjointed numbering suggests there
should be at least a few more super
powered youths on the loose the magic 8
ball may actually be a clue in and of
itself that 8 aka cali will return
especially since she has clairvoyance
and other psychic abilities
we get a wide shot of the rainbow room
complete with a giant rainbow mural on
the wall and drab
benches adorned with sullen looking
children suddenly a man walks into the
room though he only sees backside
he enters and we hear good morning
children
[Applause]
the name papa refers to dr brenner who
raised and trained 11 and the other
powerful children
dr brenner continues to talk to the kids
off screen and he tells them he has
something very special planned for them
as the camera pans to a shot of another
door in the hallway
we hear heavy breathing as the door
slowly moves closer in frame
at this point the sign on the door is
clear 11.
the screen goes black and dr brenner
asks 11 are you listening
suddenly eleven opens her eyes with a
gasp it isn't quite clear if eleven is
remembering events from her past or
tracking dr brenner in the present
either way it looks like we're going to
get to learn more about eleven's past in
the upcoming season
and that's not all the day before the
newest teaser dropped for stranger
things season 4 the stranger things
youtube account released a different
teaser which was even more cryptic
while people originally seemed confused
by the images of random objects on a set
of control room screens
upon closer inspection we see that many
of those objects appear in the newest
trailer as well one disturbing
difference however is that the first
teaser now seems to be an
after image as in after the rainbow room
is destroyed
we see shots of a door handle the
rainbow room with flickering lights a
blood spatter table
a bloody chessboard with its pieces
scattered a bloody magic 8-ball what
looks like a bunch of sticky notes and
blood on the ground
next to numbered dice the unexplained
shots are rendered even creepier in
light of the new teaser did dr brenner's
special plan caused the destruction was
it 11
or the other children either way
something horrible seems to have
happened and we're anxious to find out
what it was
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite new shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one